what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and this chapter of dragon ball
super was exactly what we've been
waiting for
so make sure to stay tuned for that if
you do enjoy seeing these dragon ball
super videos on the channel
the best thing you could do is smash
that like button and share this video
with any cultured saiyans that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future dragon ball
videos and while you impatiently wait
for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my brand new
podcast called the dragon ball virgin
where my friend who hasn't watched anime
and i discussed the entire series from
beginning to end park by arc we're also
gonna have special guests like
geekdom101 and the anime dude who were
on the last episode
so check it out if you want to
re-experience the glory of dragon ball
all over again
and if you never watched the original
series before this is a great
opportunity to experience it with us for
the first time
you can find the dragon ball virgin
podcast on spotify apple podcast
and wherever else you listen to podcasts
link in the description
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and
all if you'll remember last chapter
merus died shinigami style by refusing
to stay impartial he sacrificed his
pretty awesome angel life so that he
could help protect the universe and also
complete goku's training
it would have felt pretty cheap if
meadows just handled the problem of moro
for us while our guys couldn't do
anything so rather than that
meru's helped set things up so that goku
could succeed he did
nerf moro by breaking his magic crystals
but he still left him for goku to beat
i've been saying that we'll get to see
mastered ultra instinct in this arc and
i was even more sure of that
when we got the iconic back image of
goku last chapter which seemed like
a nod back to the super saiyan 1
transformation on namic
and i think that's significant because
this chapter definitely felt similar to
that but obviously there are important
differences too
that we'll look at anyways an aura was
radiating from goku's body
while jocko is wondering if merus died
and if goku is okay
goku says that merus taught him an
important lesson namely that he's not
fighting alone
this has been very true for this arc as
goku points out he was saved by vegeta
then dende and then merus who straight
up gave up his life in the process
notably meru's helped nerfed moro too
goku was upset
at the end of last chapter because of
merusa's death and here whis wonders if
he'll be able to properly control his
emotions for mastered ultra instinct
it is a different kind of transformation
compared to super saiyan after all
and goku is able to seemingly let go and
put his emotions in check
he unclenched his fist and breathes out
looking calm again
in reference to what whis was saying it
seems clear that he is able to control
his emotions now
he doesn't rush at morrow for revenge
but rather asks
joko why he joined the galactic patrol
even jacques was like
do we really have time for this but goku
is calm cool and collected and wants an
answer
jaco finally screams that he wanted to
help preserve peace in the galaxy and as
a side note he adds the uniform is just
awesome which is pretty hilarious it
makes sense for jocko i suppose but i
must say those uniforms are not
on say an armor level my favorite are
the shoulder less blue versions that
teen gohan and goku wore while they
trained in the hyperbolic time chamber
before the cell fight
now that's my preferred aesthetic but
fashion aside goku answers that merus
felt the same way
that he wanted to preserve peace in the
universe goku says as a galactic patrol
agent
that is his duty too he can't let moro
have his way with their home
moro finally returns wondering where
merus is and goku informs him that menus
is gone and that goku
will beat him and we get an epic moment
where goku says even though merus is
gone
he will live on in him and i love that
sentiment always will when someone shows
as much character and virtue as merus
did he continues to inspire people after
he's gone his life
and example ripples through eternity
whether he's a fictional character or
not
and with that goku transforms this is it
people a calm face transformation
great force surrounds him and we
straight up tells us that we are about
to experience
perfected ultra instinct and i like the
way it happens the great force
disappears
rather than a huge aura kicking up rocks
and such we have
extreme quiet you can hear the leaves
rustling
and then within that silence we see
silver-haired goku in his perfected
ultra instinct form
he entered it willingly calmly and i
really like the fact that it is
characterized by stillness
rather than the ground shattering and
waves raging it's a nice touch
moro is shocked at the new form and
jocko mentions that silver hair is a new
color in his book
sort of poking fun at just how many
saiyan hair colors we've gone through
thus far
and yeah we can totally poke fun at that
while also appreciating how epic
and hype this moment is we saw how badly
morrow crushed all our guys
he flexed on them in the most brutal way
possible
they didn't stand a chance but now we
get payback
as goku starts slowly approaching moro
moro is the one worried and freaking out
he can probably sense goku's power but
also his confidence
and screams for him to stay back goku's
speed is next level and he stops moro
from launching his attack before moro
can even respond
goku effortlessly dodges moro while
landing elegant yet powerful hits of his
own
moro has trouble accepting he's out
class unlike goku he's losing his cool
calling goku a worm and desperately
trying to land a shot while goku blocks
them all without even turning to face
him or look at him and as nice as it is
to see goku flexing
on the previously overconfident moral
it's even nicer when whis and beerus
compliment him
beerus comments that goku is fine tuning
his moves more and more and whis agrees
and this isn't even the last of their
compliments but more on that later
morrow asks how is goku dodging and goku
responds he's not thinking his body is
acting on its own and deciding how to
dodge
it's very similar to the philosophy
behind tanjiro's selfless state in demon
slayer by letting go and not
trying martial artists are able to
attain a higher level you are no longer
an individual acting you become
one with the action and i really like
that they brought that philosophy into
super
i much prefer letting go and mastery of
emotions being the source of power
rather than
anger on a philosophical level although
i'm not taking anything away from the
epicness of anger-based transformations
they have their own charm to be sure
moro is not hearing it though i
personally believe that as a dude very
wrapped up in his ego and emotions
moro can't even believe goku let alone
begin to emulate him
in contrast to goku's stillness moro
causes a disruptive scene by charging to
full power
it's like a small dog with a lot of bark
though and goku's stillness is like a
much stronger dog
who doesn't feel the need to bark at all
he's got nothing to prove
he calmly lifts moro in the air without
even touching him with a move
very reminiscent of when roshi lifted
kid goku and dragon ball
during the first world tournament he was
in he called the move
lightning flash surprise attack here
goku similarly can lift and immobilize
the opponent
it's pretty hilarious too since it
renders the fully powered up
and charging moro completely powerless
goku doesn't even need to lay a hand on
him to do this
it's pure ownage then goku lands a solid
punch right in moro's stomach a
satisfying punch that even caused beerus
and whis to close their eyes because
of the force it created it's like the
stillness around goku is ultra
concentrated power
and with an attack like this he just
releases it and the shock waves are felt
on a planetary level
beerus says perfectly done whis is even
surprised
to see a rare bit of respect from beerus
but beerus straight up says he'll show
respect where it's due
and that the way goku is fighting is
godlike
if that isn't hype i don't know what is
i do feel bad for people who are really
hoping for vegeta to be the star
here because i do not see how he's gonna
compete with this level of power anytime
soon as goku notices beerus and whis
beerus tells him to finish the job so
they can eat
classic beerus moro looks absolutely
horrible right now he pretty much
got yamcha goku as he did with frieza on
namek
says that his opponent must realize by
now that he can't beat him
moro can barely pull himself up and goku
is like well now you know the pain and
suffering your victims felt
moro was upset that this worm as he
called him is lecturing him as if he was
a god and as far as this world goes
beetle straight up just said he fights
like one so why not lecture him like one
too
we then get a pretty familiar moment the
enemy is overpowered but his ego can't
take it
he starts speaking how he's the supreme
life form in the galaxy after he just
got wrecked and he starts going after
the planet since he can't beat the man
but goku won't give him the time to do
that he kicks him and a boulder falls on
him
morrow's fall from arrogant supervillain
to disgraceful crybaby is pretty much
complete
the dude starts crying for help and
begging for goku not to kill him the
galactic patrol has sentenced morrow to
death though
and after goku confirms that he rips off
his uniform
saying he is going to fight moro like an
earthling from here on out
and beerus has a bad feeling about this
this is the end of this epic chapter
right here
now we are seeing here the same thing we
saw when frieza repeatedly begged for
mercy on namek
only to turn on goku again and again and
take advantage of his kindness
it's likely that moro 2 is trying to
take advantage of goku's character the
fact that goku ripped off the uniform
after mentioning
death and the fact that recently was
brought up how he likes to not
kill guys because then he'll get to
fight them again
later if they try anything it definitely
seems like goku is going to show moral
mercy
that's probably why beerus has a bad
feeling still though until next chapter
we can't be sure that things will go
down like they did on namek
or if we'll get some new factors and
thought processes thrown in
let me know what you think is gonna
happen next and let me know how you've
been enjoying this arc as a whole
so far we got perfected ultra instinct
finally which i'm very happy about
i look forward to seeing how things wrap
up and if there will be more twists
that allow vegeta to play a bigger role
but like i said i don't see him reaching
goku's level in this arc
if he does i'd be pleasantly surprised
but surprised nonetheless
and as things stand it doesn't look like
goku will need
any more help but as we know in shonen a
lot of twists can happen so let's just
wait and see
and that is it for this one thanks for
watching if you do
enjoy seeing these dragon ball super
reviews on this channel and want to keep
them coming the best thing you can do is
smash that like button and share this
video with any cultured saiyans that you
know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future dragon ball videos and while you
impatiently wait for the next chapter to
drop
feel free to check out my brand new
podcast called the dragon ball version
where my friend who doesn't watch anime
and i discuss the entire series from
beginning to end arc by
arc we're also going to have special
guests like geekdom101 and the anime
dude
who were on the last episode so check it
out if you want to re-experience the
glory of dragon ball all over again
and if you never watched the original
series before this is a great
opportunity to experience it with us for
the first time
you can find the dragon ball version
podcast on spotify apple podcast and
wherever else you listen to podcasts
link in the description i also want to
thank all of you because the channel has
been growing faster than ever and it's
unreal
we passed 980 000 subscribers and are
actually approaching 1 million
subscribers
and it's all thanks to you guys and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad
over on patreon and here on youtube who
helped make videos like this one
possible
between patreon and the youtube join
function we have over 100 patrons right
now
which is just mind-blowing and amazing
first and foremost i want to thank the
patrons of legend
the ones acknowledged by lord tuigo
himself alpha sigma
and liam thompson and are the one tier
patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans ingrata the world acquire
respect pate hepa jonathan king rathu
and aura emperor otaku
thomas jones ken mono admirath and
christopher
torley and our pro hero tier patrons the
one and only gilgamesh who's currently
the most donated overall champion of the
world
nothing but a fan kings eldris anatoly
kazowski angel
crews cricket xp joe stanton very gucci
alicia actor hinokami and water bonnie
parks jason wilson florian
joanne garcia steelers mick sheamus
jessica kelefon
deadly saint and stern hawkins once
again thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
animeopro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here
and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord
where we talk about anime life and of
course thank memes so check out
patreon.com animeoutpro link in the
description if you're interested
you can also join the youtube channel
and a lot of you have been doing that
by clicking that blue join button next
to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you will get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you